monsieur gmail bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation sur arte france
vous trouvez à beyrouth où d'abord
quelle est la situation actuellement la
situation aujourd'hui est assez calme à
beyrouth
on nous nous sommes en train de faire
face à deux crises majeures
donc comme tout le monde nous sommes en
train de faire face à une crise tout
d'abord sanitaires et et est relative au
corona comme tout le monde mais aussi
nous sommes en train de faire face à une
crise majeure qui est une crise
économique et sociale du duo à la
faillite totale de l'état et je dirais
même que c'est une faillite politique et
économique et cela est en train de de
dégénérer comme vous êtes en train de
voir dans les rues avec des
manifestations qui sont en train de
demander le certaine stabilité politique
et économique pour pour pouvoir
stabiliser la situation aujourd'hui nous
avons un dollar qui est qui est monté à
peu près de plus de moitié la ville
libanaise était à mille cinq cents le
dollar était à mille cinq cents la livre
libanaise ou une bible à dollars pour
1500 livres libanaises aujourd'hui nous
sommes à plus de 4000
donc vous voyez ça presque doublé donc
tout le monde donc ça s'est traduit pour
les libanais cette crise économique dans
la vie de tous les jours il ya un
renchérissement de tous les produits
alimentaires et et de toul et de tous
les produits que nous achetons et nous
avons aussi un problème nous avons un
problème qu'il est impossible
aujourd'hui d'acheter des produits à
l'international
donc la société libanaise qui était une
société qui était assez dépendant des
produits internationaux et surtout
européens arrivent aujourd'hui à bouée
n'arrive même plus à acheter c'est ses
produits primaires il n'y a que le que
l'essence les médicaments et certaines
denrées comme la farine qui sont
subventionnées mais sinon tout le reste
est presque impossible d'achat donc nous
faisons face aujourd'hui à un véritable
à une véritable faillite du divan et je
trouve que ceci est vraiment dommage
une à mon avis une des principale
responsabilité incombe aujourd'hui en
fait que le hezbollah qui a pris l'état
libanais en victime mais il a pris il a
pris en otage complètement qui veut
changer le régime libanais qui est un
régime capitalistique libéral en un
régime très similaire au régime syrien
ou bien au régime iranien et aujourd'hui
on voit que cela influence énormément
les le monde civil à beyrouth
les manifestations ont repris ce
week-end et au delà même c'était il ya
environ une semaine que tout a commencé
alors on sait que c'est à tripoli où
vous et elles ont été les plus violentes
pourquoi la ville de tripoli en premier
lieu la ville de tripoli est une ville
qui est qui est une des villes les plus
pauvres de beyrouth
même si c'est la deuxième ici on peut
dire la deuxième capitale du liban mais
en même temps ce qui est très très
pauvres c'est une vive qui a qui a fait
sortir énormément de politiciens et des
politiciens prennent en titre est riche
et qui ne s'occupe pas de la ville donc
on peut dire on peut dire quelque part
qu'il ya eu une certaine révolte
vis-à-vis à toute la classe politique
qui existe aujourd'hui à beyrouth qui
existe au liban et ceci à commencer par
tripoli il faut dire que tripoli avait
été la scène d'un d'un d'un spectacle
extraordinaire durant les manifestations
de d'octobre octobre 2019 qui a été une
scène de révolution pacifique calme et
vraiment
extraordinaire aujourd'hui tripoli
s'enflamme parce que tripoli demande
comme tous les libanais une certaine
stabilité une certaine un certain
bien-être économique que l'état libanais
n'arrive plus à a donné à tous ses
citoyens
conséquence le liban s'est tourné vers
le fmi ils demandent une aide la france
d'ailleurs à estime que le gouvernement
libanais doit mettre en oeuvre sans
délai une série de réformes pour pouvoir
en bénéficier est ce possible tout
d'abord cette série de réformes
écoutez le liban avait demandé à
plusieurs reprises à la communauté
internationale lors ce qu'on a fait
paris 1 paris de même paris iii et puis
dernièrement la conférence est qui s'est
déroulé à paris en 2000 je crois 2017 ou
2016 au site shoumoukh pas nous avions
demandé l'aide et le souhait le soutien
de la communauté internationale et en
contrepartie de quoi il y aurait eu des
réformes qui allait s'imposer
malheureusement ces réformes n'ont
jamais eu lieu depuis 2000 jusqu'à
aujourd'hui ces réformes n'ont jamais eu
lieu
ce sont des réformes qu aujourd'hui le
peuple demande ils demandent ils
demandent de que l'argent qui a été
dilapidé l'argent qui a été volé par
l'état soit rendue que les politiciens
qui ont commis des crimes aux biens qui
ont commis des vols de biens publics
soient aussi emprisonnée et jusqu'à
présent rien de tout ça ne se passe à
mon avis tant que nous sommes sous
tutelle iranienne et où tant que le
hezbollah qui contrôlent et dirigent et
couvre tous ces voleurs et tous les to
les des lapidaires des biens publics
nout tout genre de de changement est
très très difficile et ces réformes vont
être très difficiles à adopter s'ils
abandonnent hosni n'enlève pas sa main
et ne couvre plus les dirigeants il faut
dire qu'aujourd'hui les grandes réformes
sont ceux de l'électricité du liban
souffre des ports aéroports dé du
système douanier et tous ceux là sont
sous contrôle direct
ce pôle à la semaine dernière hassan
diab a adopté un plan de relance
économique mais sur lequel n'était pas
d'accord on va dire le président michel
larronde pourquoi aujourd'hui michel
aron cristallise les tensions
écoutez je ne sais pas s'il était
d'accord ou pas aujourd'hui il ya une
réunion à baabda où le président a
invité les chefs et les leaders
politiques pour leur expliquer ce plan
économique donc je crois qu'il est
important pour ce plan power économique
en ce qui me concerne et je réitère ma
position ce plan économique n'a aucune
valeur si les réformes politiques de
fond n'ont pas lieu au niveau politique
et au niveau surtout du contrôle de
l'état
il faut qu'il y ait une véritable
libéralisation de la classe politique
afin que les voleurs ne soient pas eux
mêmes les juges de leurs propres armes
nadine du mail merci beaucoup d'avoir
pris le temps de répondre à nos
questions je rappelle que vous étiez en
direct depuis beyrouth où vous êtes
député
merci